[Musique]
600 accidents de chasse depuis
l'ouverture plusieurs morts des dizaines
de blessés graves dimanche dernier un
homme tue son fils un garçon de 14 ans
on n'a jamais vu cela depuis que la
chasse est devenu un sport démocratique
et que des milliers d'amateurs en ont
fait leur distraction du dimanche plus
grave encore il ya quelques semaines un
industriel parisien monsieur le comte et
tué dans des circonstances mystérieuses
personnes parmi ses compagnons de chasse
de ceux désignant comme responsable
lieux du drame heudicourt dans l'eure
alors voilà je suis au service
de monsieur richard je suis son cas j'ai
assisté enfin j'étais pour ainsi dire
pour raison à la clients alors voyons
vous étiez à quel endroit au moment où
ça s'est passé mais nous étions tout
près du château de ricaud et vous vous
maniez le rabat la batterie moi je me
lève à voter oui alors vous avez
continuer à arpenter le terrain puis
tout d'un coup vous êtes arrivé alors
qu'est ce que vous avez vu c'est à dire
que c'était au bilan certains bonbons et
ils ont failli tromper le docteur et un
docteur sur ma gauche
l'auteur pistor ils ont dit ils l'ont
appelé quoi alors sans savoir pourquoi
puisque elle et moi je croyais que
c'était pour rire agit bien de décès du
coup qu'il est un bon chien on dit qu'il
a la paix le docteur piste ho avec son
chien pour le rechercher le gibier puis
après j'ai entendu arrêter là bas tu y
as blessé j'arrêté labatut et puis au
bout d'un petit un petit moment on a vu
un petit rassemblement
la victime était tombée on savait pas
qu'il y avait quelqu'un on il ya un
blessé
j'aime penser dit certain qu'il a été
plombé ses avis et faire du moins du
plombe comme ça arrive quelques offres
sont vives et puis là on arrivé là bas
j'y arrive et qu'on mettait on finissait
de mettre en voiture vous l'enlever
c'est tout ce que j'ai vu sur le terrain
l'occident paraît invraisemblable
[Musique]
on chasse en plaine à découvert
la ligne des tireurs à la fuite à plus
de 250 mètres des rabatteurs et pourtant
un homme est touché alors monsieur le
comte était à ce poste-là jeu richard le
président tient à tirer de la haute
levade 275 mètres fait la chasse canton
l'aiment c'est passionnant même et
surtout sans le romantisme de la
littérature spécialisée sans la poétiser
et sans l'aïr il reste qu'elle est avant
tout une ambiance un climat notre propos
n'est pas ici d'engager un débat le
gibier garde toujours sa chance
vous allez le voir dans un instant on
peut être pour ou contre
comme on est pour ou contre les courses
de taureaux mais là n'est pas la
question
aujourd'hui on tue aussi des chasseurs
pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
zéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravement face à la ligne des tireurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vacances
quoi qu'il en soit en l'état de la
législation peut-on faire quelque chose
des chasseurs répondent très bien dans
les battues en principe quand on parle
surtout à l'ouverture de la chasse ou
c'est dangereux c'est dans les
betteraves par exemple dans tous les
couverts tout le monde un peu le sang
chaud le jour de l'ouverture
alors quand on arrive à certains moments
qu'on a poussé les perdreaux dans les
couverts sa part de tous côtés
alors les gens ont tendance à pas écouté
alors c'est là à ce moment là que je
commence à rentrer en ligne d'hier il
faut tout de même et freiner un petit
peu mais alors ça prenne les gens y a
des moments ça va pas toujours tout seul
mais c'est ce qui évite en principe les
accidents dans ces conditions quelles
sont à votre avis les mesures de
sécurité indispensable il faut prendre
parce qu'on chasse en collectivité comme
vous mais je crois qu'une des premières
précautions et de ne jamais conserver
les cartouches en dehors des battues
dans son fusil très souvent un chasseur
peut en ayant conservé des cartes aux
gens son fusil appuierez actionné la
gâchette et provoque un accident c'est à
votre avis le précepte numéro oui
évidemment mais ça c'est sûr et en plus
il ya une chose très importante à mon
avis c'est la façon de tenir son fusil
et à peu près deux façons de tenir son
physique correcte à mon avis c'est de
tenir cassé sous son bras ou alors fermé
et comme ça sur l'épaule c'est ça une
façon extrêmement dangereuse qui est de
tenir comme ceux ci est balayé ce n'est
pas parce que ça c'est une chose qu'on
voit assez souvent avec j'appelle
d'ailleurs la face on assassine on voit
les humeurs du canon qui se promène de
son voisin c'est très agréable
précautions les plus élémentaires c'est
quand on voit une pièce de gibier il
faut la laisser filer si on n'est pas
certain d'avoir le champ libre et de
pouvoir tirer sur j'ai une idée je ne
sais pas ce qu'elle vaut évidemment rien
ne ressemble plus à une cartouche
ordinaires qu'une cartouche qui tue une
cartouche ou une balle mais est-ce qu'on
ne pourrait pas différencier la couleur
carrément faire que tous les armuriers
se mettent d'accord pour avoir une
certaine couleur qui serait
par exemple noir et qui montreraient que
c'est ou de la chevrotine ou une balle
parce qu'on peut très bien se tromper
quand on a dans une dans une
cartouchière deux espèces monsieur vous
êtes chasseur vous avez été au courant
comme tout le monde de cet accident de
10 courts quelle est votre opinion
bref j'ai l'impression qu'en plaine
c'est extrêmement difficile d'avoir un
accident grave de l'accident qui était
sans doute provoqué par une erreur d'un
chasseur qui a dû mettre une ballerine
chevrotine par erreur mais en plein je
ne trouve pas que la chose soit prêt
dangereuse
je pense effectivement que le chasseur
si c'est un accident a dû confondre deux
cartouches en les mettant ensemble dans
ce centre où chacun pioche dans arrive
parce que les gens sont pros nerveux et
n'ont pas été habitués à la chasse tout
petits à suivre les chasses savoir
comment ça se passe à savoir qu'un fusil
tu es si ça tue le gibier ça peut être
mais les gens de même façon
personnellement en chassant il m'est
arrivé d'être tout seul dans la plaine
avec mon frère s'embête de moi un jour
de temps couvert
un perdreau part entre nous deux je vis
mon perdreaux on était 2 j'ai quand même
plombée mon frère et vous même avez vous
été victime des excès et moi moelle est
un rabatteur
dans le tchat organisé comme la nôtre on
arrive en prêt pas tellement loin de la
ligne des affûts j'ai reçu un coup de
fusil
je me suis couché pour le deuxième qui
est passé au dessus de la tête mais
j'avais trois plombs dans le front enfin
si ç'avait été drôle c'est pareil c'est
bien qu'on soit entre amis on n'a jamais
su d'où le coup de fusil était parti si
par malheur et vous arrivez un accident
par et quelle serait votre attitude je
sais pas gérer immédiatement et
il n'y a absolument aucune hésitation
sur ce point sont a provoqué un accident
il faut immédiatement intervenir au
point de la victime
président de chasse arrête la chasse je
crois que dans ce domaine il n'est pas
question de dissimuler l'accident si
c'est invraisemblable quand je dis
région m'ont fait on était tous les
époux voyager me suivez j'étais des
lancers mais quand on est en équipe
organisée c'est quelquefois bien
difficile de savoir
ah ben moi je c'est à dire que je vous
dirais que je n'aurais pas mis le shorty
ou de balle d'abord si bien que je
n'aurais peut-être pas dit que c'est moi
qui avais tiré parce que je n'aurais pas
su que j'avais mis une sourdine une
balle
donc c'est une chose absolument
invraisemblable non moi si vous aviez
provoqué un accident je l'aurais dit
immédiatement et il m'est arrivé
d'envoyer dès que tu arrives et
d'envoyer des plombs à des camarades
elle savait très bien que ce témoin qui
avait envoyé les plantes puis je disais
que c'était moi je n'avais pas ne
souffrait pas l'ombre d'une hésitation
est ce que les risques grandissants
qu'on rencontre lâchait ce vous amènera
un jour ou l'autre abandonner votre
sport qui semblait théâtre sport favori
certainement pas parce que
personnellement je suis très prudent il
m'est jamais arrivé quand même de de
faire du mal à mon prochain
en pratiquant ce sport savez ya
malheureusement il ya un bout de temps
que je sache gimont premier permis à
l'âge de 16 ans et je chasse toujours
avec tes amis
est ce que le fait que les accidents se
multiplient nous amènerait à abandonner
la chasse un jour ou l'autre nous
sûrement pas
non je ne crois pas parce que j'ai la
charge depuis j'ai pas moins de 13 14
ans je vais à la charge tout le temps je
n'ai jamais cessé sauf comme de chirac
pendant la période de l'occupation
j'aime la chasse aux riches que ne me
gêne pas si vous voulez mais est ce que
vous avez peur maintenant à la chasse
non nous n'avons de ne riez pas la
chasse à cause des risques
ah non non mais si je faisais un
accident je crois que j'apprenne à
l'achat
[Musique]